this notion that the psychics when
they're hearing from demons that it's
truth that you can point to that'll
spook people out because you're saying
when there were three you know this
happened
with falsehood what's the percentage I
mean how
how much deception is there and how much
truth is there okay well anything that
they report that has already happened
they can report that that's going to be
true of course that's going to be 100
accurate
in order to prove to the person that's
right now everything else that they say
because now you're hanging on to every
word that comes out of their mouth now
right because they were able to tell you
what you did last week they were able to
tell you your mom and dad and things
like Dante and and this that and the
other right now you're like oh okay I
wonder what else they're gonna say so
anything that's a prediction
is already a lie even if they end up
coming true Michael and I'll tell you
why because they don't know everything
only God does only God does right but
can they are they good guessers
absolutely